[Music]
hey everyone I'm Jenny director this is
the daily Jenny and we've got you
covered
talking all things VMAs last night and I
brought some reinforcements some
beauties of mine without et style editor
Marissa Runyon hello my fellow ET online
host and producer Deidre Behar hello
just like you guys but we want to know
right off the bat what did you guys
think of the VMAs you know how do you
think they've lost touch
are you still entertained by them I mean
love it or hate it there's always
something to talk about from the Video
Music Awards don't you think every
single that you ever were buzzed worthy
moments we're tweeting about it I want
to know what everyone's face exactly so
let us know you guys but one thing we
can always count on with the VMAs which
is actually why I still tune in besides
the fact that I work for only at the MTV
Awards you do do the celebrity claws
come out you know and no one holds back
and um they wasted no time this year
right off the bat the top of the show
cardi B opened with a little quick tease
she pulled a fast one thinking there was
baby culture in her arms there was
actually a moon person but but this is
the one small dig a slight shade that
people are talking about today is it a
diss at Nicki Minaj Queen you guys
decide here's a here's a taste of what
she said last night
the Empress yeah I mean a lot of people
are saying it's a dig at Nicki Minaj's
Queen
I think the evil wife solidified that it
was Shady totally I think look I love a
word
regal Baroness Marchioness I think
cardies my soul sister in like weird
vocabulary crime right but the evil
laugh just kind of shows like there
might be a queen in the building but
there's also an empress not exactly has
been Hawking the record queen of course
and I mean I if you that was a drinking
game I would be wasted I just walked in
the last couple weeks right so a lot of
people are seeing that cardi kind of
took a chance to take a little jab out
her you know but it's the place to do it
it isn't the place to do it right and
she knew she was opening up this show
like I wouldn't put it past her to kind
of do that and Nicki was right there in
the audience front row and then you know
what the rest of the shady moments all
kind of had a Nicki Minaj theme whether
she's her brand
it's her brand right but the next moment
I want to talk about is Tiffany had a
shoe actually and donor Nikki will come
back into play here but we got to set it
up first gotta set up to shake any
Hatter's was onstage presenting the next
award where she took a diss a little bit
at fifth harmony shouting out Camilla
Kibeho
take a look
[Music]
Camila Cabello is nominated for [ __ ]
y'all know I can't read that here speak
English and that's mostly anybody's look
she's nominated for five be amazed
tonight
[Applause]
so so those of you watching it wrong -
harmony Oh God
[Applause]
Oh Tiffany went there Tiffany went there
yeah I know I kind of like my inner
feminist wants to die a little and I
totally cringe at those moments but at
the end of the day I mean I feel like a
broken record VMAs it's the time to do
it Tiffany Haddish on brand for her
she's a comedian she's paid to push
buttons and if we didn't have people who
are provocateurs like Tiffany Haddish or
Kevin Hart what would we be talking
about today as long as it's not
malicious or rooted in like you know I'm
making fun of a personal tragedy that
you might have gone through if we're
just like poking fun you know fit the
harmony great band they split up I'm
cool with it right how'd you feel young
MTV really you know crowd and it's like
they're definitely partying before
during and after this thing so you know
no one's trying to like put their most
put together face for it it's like a
really loose fun environment to do that
I can't take it too seriously dude
obviously it's just a hiatus time right
now for fifth harmony they're prepping
for their big solo stuff you know I mean
their time and they have their time at
the VMAs they've collected a few of
their own they've performed with and
without Camilla so let's take it easy on
them I don't Amin I think more than
anything everyone's putting out hot fire
tracks everything and we just Camille is
here because she put out the most stuff
and her stuff was nominated I guarantee
you normanni will be there next year and
maybe the other girls too and look what
she far off Camilla took home artist of
the year and video of the yeah you know
she she was praising Camilla at fifth
Harmony's expense but fifth Harmony's
fine we'll see you guys in a couple
years I'm praying and in fact nicki
minaj she clapped back she came for
norma she came for Tiffany Haddish in
support of and so don't be coming for
fifth harmony because normanni is that
[ __ ]
[Applause]
I'm just saying classic yeah I was like
thank you for this like I need these
moments it was just like a little
top-heavy though I mean they can all be
that B I hate that for this by the way I
feel like they're all just such they're
such talented vocalist singers dancers
their total packages these girls and it
brings me back I'm gonna sound so dated
nope nope if you wanted to talk about JT
like I was here to talk about JC Shaw's
a menage that's normani like go girl go
defend normanni
Tiffany managed by live Camilla we can
all have our faves it's okay I'm gonna
say Nikki also is pure comedy lately -
you don't mean I don't I have reason to
believe that the shade is not that
serious
no she doesn't take herself too
seriously in anything she knows what
she's doing - she's just being Nikki
which she is the Queen you know
especially mouch got a lot of headlines
today so yeah good work oh yeah I'm
still talking about her and in fact
that's why I want to talk about one more
point you know there's been a lot of
drama right now between nikki minaj and
travis kashi
essentially called out travis for having
kylie promote his tour his merge which
facts like it led to peace the album
sales of astral roll Travis's album so
which is why astral Travis is Scott's
album is number one in Queen debuted at
number two on the Billboard charts Nikki
had something to say about it but last
night Travis reminded who's number one
so Sam Somerset
[Music]
the Queen of Soul Aretha Franklin asked
to world right now
now you could make the argument that
that wasn't direct shade but on defense
he didn't say anything thank you the
best tribute of the night he's a rapper
it's like it is DNA it'll be
braggadocious you everyone out everybody
you gotta scream it exactly I'm not a
hundred percent sure that it was that's
for a total dig at Nikki I know people
were making a lot of fuss about he and
Kylie were in the audience that perhaps
got their seat moved to be a little
further away Brandi's I'm not sure
that's actually true but I think he's
just proud of his success yeah and I'm
here for that I am glad he said
something though because Nikki had her
moment today on Queen Radio on beats one
you know so she's been dragging him so
at least he reminded the folks in his
fans it's like his albums number one so
good on congratulation and he did it
without slamming her saying her name or
dirtying her nature just a reminder of
the church how Kylie was in the audience
by the way they cut away to her look at
Lord the Met Gala
she just looks poor things like enjoyed
a little you're up there performing like
this is right what did you guys think do
you think Travis Scott was throwing
shade at Nikki we want to know but we
are going to talk about some other
really two most talked about moments and
the stuff you didn't see on TV beginning
with the much talked-about
Aretha Franklin tribute courtesy of
Madonna yeah soap Madonna actually took
to Instagram today there's been a lot of
backlash about it people felt like it
was very toned death death excuse me
tone death and then she made it more
about herself than Aretha she went up
there to present video there but before
that she actually paid tribute to me
thought she took to Instagram today and
said unfortunately most people have
short attention spans are so quick to
judge I love Aretha resp ect she also
revealed that it wasn't up to her MTV
asks you're gonna be up to presenting
video the year can you say a few words
or what I read them meant to you and
your career and her influence and I do
feel it was a little bit long-winded but
what else you're supposed to do she said
it wasn't her idea so what do you guys
think well she's Madonna people want to
hear from her and she has interesting
things to say an interesting life
experiences so you know it is
exactly about her idea but she did what
she you know was asked to do just what
had gone about it a lot different I
think I think when you are given the
incredible platform to eulogize an icon
like Aretha Franklin
you can tell ten percent about me and my
journey and you do 90 percent are--those
life legacy accomplishments and I think
I think Madonna in her Instagram caption
used the word anecdote the word anecdote
to me means like oh I ran into Marissa
in the restroom yeah that's a panic
totally uh giving you my life story is a
lot for you to digest as a viewer it was
a lot for me to digest and Madonna even
acknowledged herself she was like I know
you're all wondering why I'm telling you
this there is a connection it just took
me a little too long yeah yeah and
that's my point cuz yes of course make
it personal ya know we want to know
especially let's not deny Madonna
herself as an icon too so hearing one
music icon praise another music legend
oh I'm here for it but I think that get
to the point right she made it a little
too long a little too much about this
one particular story which really could
have been like a 90 second thing is I
also just wonder like in the course of
Madonna's really long and lengthy career
I'm sure she has like fond memories of
being with Aretha
I feel like Madonna kind of touched a
little bit too much on like oh I sang
her song when I was auditioning for
something I would have been enthralled
to hear a story about all the time I sat
together at the Grammys or the time that
we did this together or just something
maybe to bring it more a little not
really well thought out overall I get
that it's a close turn around yeah but
I'm not really well maybe she doesn't
have that bad experience of that story
with Aretha so then go back to what I
originally said just eulogize her life
talk about what her legacy means go
through her videos and how they just
speak to so many generations and
transcend so many people I don't know it
was a little tone deaf for me and it
wouldn't be your first time right now
you guys up on et online.com we actually
broke down some of Madonna's
questionable tributes over the years to
Prince to Michael Jackson go take a look
at that et on line one
you know I love you magic all right
another moment everyone's talking about
is Ariana Grande and Pete Davidson yeah
may their red carpet debut as an engaged
couple look at them there Pete really
dressed for the occasion I think on
brand I'm Brad I agree totally on brand
the fact that she's not an oversized
sweatshirt - I was actually right and
that's right literally they were really
cute last night though it was literally
like their problem yeah so cute they're
on the red carpet posing like it was
legit prom I love it and they're
adorable I love when whoever is having
their night in this case it was re
honest night she was the one performing
and nominated I love when the
significant other takes the backseat and
just kind of is there to be loving and
supportive and I felt that from him the
whole night he wasn't hamming it up it
wasn't his moment it wasn't look at me
in the camera it was just I'm here for
you it was beautiful yeah and they gave
us some great moments from the telecast
like in the audience and in fact after
ariana won best pop they shared a little
smooch no cue yeah I think we have some
b-roll of it - or asking you a shot of
it but ya know Ariana accept the best
pop and then you know smoochy-smooch
right there from Pete which is cute and
even leave a scene he was like rocking
out to her yeah even a rod a run for his
money that all the boyfriends legit
they're so supportive but like best
boyfriend award goes to the two of them
absolutely you know a rod was the ideal
boy Instagram boyfriend less like videos
like yeah this is being thank you for
giving us that great content on your
Instagram story but I think it just
shows how supportive because the heat
was of JLo and her big night I mean the
video Vanguard performance from JLo at
all hands for JLo it was a breathtaking
in so many levels in fact you guys if
you missed it here's a little taste
[Applause]
ghetto JLo all the time I just I can I
just almost 50 years old I've been in
the game for 20 years it's like that was
a highlight of the night for me she's
amazing you know something you guys
don't know and I witness tells us that
the drink lines at Radio City Music Hall
were so so long but when JLo came out
for that performance everyone ditched
ditched the bar they're like no we gotta
go watch into words truly what she means
to me like on a personal level I'm just
you stand for Beyonce like I stand for
Jennifer Lopez
I would watch can we like invent the
lows like the new version of like her
performance her performing her awards
yes handing them out yes this woman I
was I was annoyed because I went on her
Wikipedia this morning I wanted to know
she got this big award last night how
many big awards does she like really
have she really doesn't have enough and
this is this woman is not decorated
enough for her incredible contributions
to entertainment over the last 25 or so
years and she incorporated so many
amazing elements into that performance
there was dancing which is her roots we
know her from Janet Jackson's music
videos and whatnot in living color and
the music videos all tell narratives and
stories and the fashion I mean you know
you got the Couture you got the Jenny
from the block stuff the choreography
the body like all of them and you know
also she brought up ja Rule how many was
that that got like the biggest scream in
the office during the performance was
when ja Rule came out and when she
brought out that six train got the
loudness like kind of applause and
reaction from the crowd there but that
was a moment a way to bring it back so
really that was like a turning point for
her too was around the same time she
earned the number one movie in America
and the number one album at the same
time the record right so think about
that a song that got us real hyped in
2001 yes she's still making top hits
like De Niro now today
yeah and so this woman has maintained so
much relevancy and she continues to
reinvent herself and I just I truly we
were watching it together last day I was
just in awe completely I was it was so
well deserved more Awards for Jennifer
although I love that speaking of awards
best dress maybe because nearly 20 hours
after that right after that classic
Versace moment at the Grammys she
brought Versace back on all night long
right is the definition of being on
brand yeah you can look at a photo of
her from 20 years ago or or today and
while she grows and evolves and changes
she's still so true to herself and her
personal style she's honed this look
that's cool like quintessentially JLo
absolutely and Versace is a huge part of
that absolutely talk about those looks a
little obvious Lee she's wearing Versace
the entire night and everyone around her
is Versace Versace really turned it out
she had she had TJ Copeland in Versace
his whole family all of her dancers in
Versace so she walked the carpet in this
chainmail silver Versace look look so
flawless and beautiful and this
silhouette is a so effortless on her
like drapes over her body so perfectly
the chic moon person yep yeah she knows
what works for her she does we see her
in that silhouette I feel like a lot yet
I never ever get tired of it I feel like
she always brings something new and
fresh but maintains that consistency
exactly we're just talking and that that
silhouette is so great on a curvy
silhouette and that's her that's her jam
the hair was a little too simple for the
red carpet but then when I saw the
performance I realized why I like how
she kept the whole glam look the whole
night total that's nice to keep
consistent absolutely yeah let's talk
about someone's performance so those
were all custom-made just for her this
Cape it's it's a classic for Saatchi
print it was completely encrusted in
Swarovski crystal it's silk and then
underneath it she has this completely
encrusted in Swarovski crystal bodysuit
that's like bondage inspired so it's
just perfectly fitting her body and
sparkling
they may be dancing the ape [ __ ] in
front of that guy she rips off this cape
underneath she has on this amazing
bodies dude that she kept on the whole
time for the most part and just kept
changing out those top pieces so she had
that Medusa gold medallion it was kind
of like her theme throughout so she was
wearing it on her waist and then her
dancers had it and I think she also had
one kind of icon her chest but basically
the whole thing felt very consistent and
fluid and golden theme on brand on theme
right excuse me and then this jumpsuit
or this tracksuit amazing like bedazzled
right so good that's Jenny from the
block right there and I loved it she
goes from being a babe to being like
such a boss within oh she was
effortlessly she is please do not
neglect to acknowledge this woman is
dancing full-out like well it's a
choreography doing that in little
stilettos I mean come on that's child's
play she's got to put on her boots and
she's gonna like Slayer we talked about
one of my favorite looks of the night
party because she's been a red carpet
since today her body this dress come on
this dress again fitting your curves so
perfectly so this is custom-made for her
this is Nicholas turban and it's velvet
fuchsia the draping is amazing the feel
like necklines phenomenal I love a
sleeve I love that everyone's wearing a
sleeve right now in this high slit it
was definitely a theme throughout the
night the lot of high slits and a lot of
like really interesting necklines mmm
that dress is hugging her in all the
right places I get it mama yes and she
showed up early you know I mean like she
could she wanted all of you today and
she earned it I mean that look was fired
my hair looks great too Bob yes so
unbelievably fun last night - by the way
I'm like and she took home a couple of
moon people herself but like I just
loved how much fun she was having like
that's what she's the ringleader of fun
come on yeah car you gonna be amazed
would be like me at the VMAs yes um the
guys rolling it down to
yeah Shawn Mendes this was one of my
favorite looks I would wear this right
now
so this is a Paul Smith suit that he's
wearing it's double-breasted and it was
navy and hunter green so it actually
took me a few minutes looking at this
picture because I thought it was black
and then I saw another photo I said no
my god it's color blocked and it's
perfect oh man I really cool this I need
to like the color badly you need to rip
that off his body
gladly I will gladly do it can I just
say though I do wish he either lost the
shirt or fund ended up to the top yeah I
got a joke about the shirt right or
button to the top I don't know but like
I just felt like that part I disagree
with I would style it differently that's
great it was appropriate for the night
and very cool I'm speaking of suits the
girl though women turned out she there
are some great menswear look so menswear
is such a huge trend for fall Kylie
Jenner she's wearing Tom Ford and Blake
Lively who famously doesn't have a
stylist was wearing this amazing look
she's in ralph and Bruce oh this was
just a really cool take on white
menswear for Blake I thought she looked
a little covered up for the night this
is this is the time to be sexy when we
saw people being way too sexy just being
straight-up naked for her I would have
lost the blouse
just lose the blouse and wear the suit
and show some skin I think I think Kylie
did it so perfectly pileup she's got
long sleeves there's no exposed cleavage
but at least get a little bit of a
neckline they're very sexy land and it
wasn't micro mini but it was many enough
to show off her gorgeous legs she looked
like a billionaire boss lady when she is
oh my gosh she's she's been on the cover
for that was really really good Blake
has been rocking the pantsuits during
this press tour for her movie a simple
favor and I liked a lot of them but I'm
right I'm with you it was a little too
close okay give her a top hat she would
look like one of those rock cats around
Christmastime Bob you were mentioning
that your favorite looks a thing of the
night came courtesy of some 14 year olds
legit my favorite looks of the night
where Millie Bobby Brown and grace van
der Waal and they're both 14 years old
and they completely owned it I want you
to rip those outfits off both of them
and wear them
nice so Millie Bobby Brown she's wearing
rosy isalean just ring this bra a Latin
pants or high-waisted pants in this cute
little top thing I love about the way
they both look is that they both look
totally age-appropriate but fun and
youthful and timeless all at the same
time and very on-trend their stylist
totally nailed it I think they look
fantastic and grace Vanderwall is
actually wearing an io rain dress it's a
Brazilian brand you can buy this dress
online right now it's $489 top
affordable Oh indeed your love's a
sparkle I do want to ask your opinion
yeah I don't love the Hat how do you
feel about that brand for her okay she's
a she's very kitschy yes like that's per
look if you follow her on Instagram like
that's kind of her vibe I think she took
it and made it her own which was why I
quit yes I'm just gonna elevate it
afford this award show for this carpet
yeah and she's also wearing like I don't
know if you can see in the photo but she
also brings socks with her little shoes
oh yeah again very her so cute and so
her and black shoes that match the it
was very balanced yeah for sure wow I
can buy that online thanks so much for
those yes are you guys well there's
there was actually a lot of great
fashion and we have the full gallery of
the MTV VMA red carpet we do wanna know
what you guys think what was your
favorite look of the night I got to give
you a quick shots of Shay Mitchell I
thought she looks like or to leave
entirely encrusted in beads oh yeah what
do you guys think was your favorite
looking I was your least favorite look
of the night well we're running out of
time here but you can take it to the
comment section alright let us know for
sure but Marissa did your thing you guys
so much thank you that's fun yeah
absolutely you guys we're gonna be
together for the next award show just
because we have so much tea and I'm way
too much fun I hope you guys had fun
watching it so thank you so much again
head over to ET online.com for all of
our VMA coverage and I'll be back
tomorrow with another daily Denny that's
right
[Music]
you